[Music]
you know for large-scale organizations
fabric I apologize yeah it is
interrupted by
[Music]
we have rebranded my podcast to
interrupted by Gary B so I apologize up
front if I interrupt it's only at a
sheer excitement and trying to be as
efficient with our time as possible I'm
so excited you're on the show why don't
you tell the Vayner nation who you are
and a little bit about your career and
then I'm obviously very curious to how
you thought about the book and and then
obviously I'd love to get your take on
you know current events and shoot the
[ __ ] here a little bit so sure being on
sure I'm Steve Schwarzman I'm
professionally the co-founder and
chairman and CEO of a company called
Blackstone Blackstone is the largest
company in the world that does what's
called alternative investing that's
private equity where we're one of the
largest in the world I think we're the
largest real estate globally were the
largest owner of real estate globally
hedge funds were the largest allocator
to hedge funds in the world of leveraged
credit where we extend loans and and
other types of securities to people who
want to borrow money not the largest in
the world on that because you know we
weren't one of the top more work on that
way yeah we do and we do other things
like invest in life science and growth
equity which are newer type companies
and we grow very rapidly we've got about
five hundred and fifty billion dollars
of assets which won't mean much to most
listeners yeah but but it's a lot for
sure and we're one of the most
profitable companies in money management
in the world and we have what's called a
market value which is what the stock
market values us at about sixty eight
billion dollars and I started the
company with
400,000 so in in the capitalist world
and when did you start that 1985 so
that's viewed as a success yes so so
that's where all worlds by the way what
have you that is a success yes so that's
what I do professionally obviously and
and I also do a lot of stuff with
philanthropy
which is a long word yeah but basically
I give money to start really unusual
things I started a program in China
called the Schwartzman scholars and and
what it is it's like the Rhodes
Scholarship where we take students who
were extraordinary who've already
graduated from University for graduate
degree master's in global affairs and we
bring them to China to schwartzman
college which is like an Oxford
Cambridge type of college where the
students live there that take their
meals there they have classes there and
and 40% of the students are from the
United States 20% are from China and 40%
are from other countries so basically
there are 41 countries right now sending
when do you start that started that came
up with the idea in 2011 our first class
graduated in 2017 so we have roughly
about a hundred and fifty students now
our max capacity as we're growing it is
200 these kids are astonishing literally
really astonishing and we've got
sponsorship from the president of China
the President of the United States it's
it's a very unusual thing so that that
takes some of my time but but I've also
started some other things around
artificial intelligence because I'm
concerned about the impact of AI in
terms of disruption in the workforce
it's a foregone conclusion well just
like machines for farming that's also
true yes uh and so I'm looking at
that that situation and by the same
token a I can do some astonishingly
positive things so so I ended up doing a
very large donation to MIT to start a
new college of computing which will on
the one hand push the technology forward
but on the other hand be a place where
we can take people from around the world
and figure out how to introduce this
technology on a basis where does the
minimum damage to society and people in
terms of unemployment and I've done
something similar but a little different
at Oxford University and there we
started another AI ethics thing and I
gave a big facility for the humanities
because Oxford interestingly has that's
where it started yep they're number one
in the world as MIT is in science and
Oxford's never had their humanities
departments together interesting so this
will be the first time we're building a
big Performing Arts Center we're gonna
use you know the humanities to inform
that but importantly an AI because
Oxford is got the number one philosophy
department ethics departments in the
world we're going to use that capability
to inform how humans react to artificial
intelligence a couple things LinkedIn I
know you guys are live so please fire in
your questions I know that is very much
the audience for this interview Steve
take it all the way back where were you
born and what kind of kid were you I was
born in Philadelphia okay and what kind
of kid was I was a Philly sports fan
I was then but they lost all the time so
I've transferred my loyalty wow you're
gonna move to where your current loyalty
I moved to New York 1969 fair not so so
year for the Jets and the Mets well
nobody can be for the Jets you know it's
just requires too much loyalty for too
many peers
too many decades I've consist I have not
missed a snap of a New York Jets
football game since 1982 well then then
you were a masochist you know it got
deeply loyal when they built a new
stadium I really need ya in the
Meadowlands I thought it'd be really
neat to get a box and yes go on a
regular basis well it's quite defeating
yes and you know so I give the the the
tickets away for the most part by the
end of the season did you Jets and
Giants are just Jets oh yeah but but by
the end of a season nobody will take
them I understand no it's not been the
best decade now that's for free I
understand they won't take them the
market is supply and demand my friend
except the only the only group that will
take them actually none of my people
will take them but I give the tickets
away to veterans under star and you know
disabled veterans and they take them and
they have a good time but I must tell
you you know you you you have to be an
optimist uh if you're a Jets fan or you
just love the process you know I think
when you know when I think about your
level of success or anybody else there's
just if one does not love the process
they have no shot and I genuinely you
know I have I spent so much time in
control it's it's actually fun to offset
a little bit in being super passionate
about something you don't have control
over which is why I've decided I'm gonna
buy the New York Jets because I want
control back to my happiness
well a friend of mine Woody Johnson owns
the teams I'm aware and I I try and give
him some advice some time but apparently
I'm not an effective they grew up in
Philly what kind of kid were you worried
good student where you're not sure what
kind of Hustler kid where what kind of
guy were you well I I had sort of two
lives the first was in the city and
until I was 14 and then the second was
in the suburbs so so so in this city you
know I I was I was an athlete
and I was a good student not at the top
of my class but you know I try really
hard and and that's sort of what you did
at that age was that a big conversation
in the household like be great at school
it was just assumed yeah there was no
conversation yes there was a
dictatorship it was a culture understood
of do well where were you in the lineage
were you the oldest I was the oldest so
even more so yeah you have a little bit
of pressure on that but you know I
always remember sort of being outside
and you know competing at something you
know I look I just loved sports and I
moved to the suburbs and you know it
wasn't it wasn't as difficult I mean I
grew up in an area where you know there
were broken bottles all over playgrounds
and if you played soccer against
somebody something bad could happen to
you
in the field do you feel that those
first 14 years in that kind of
environment gave you some real
advantages from a grit and kind of like
EQ kind of sense absolutely if I hadn't
been raised in a place like that I
wouldn't understand
no sort of I wouldn't have understood
evil I wouldn't have understood
understood bad behavior that that bad
things can happen to nice people yeah
one of my my closest friend when I was
young his father was assassinated when
we were about 10 in some motel I don't
know what this guy was doing but but but
my friend had had a box you know
completely filled with money
I I mean I wasn't even given money yeah
so so I was in a neighborhood that was
somewhat I guess you would call it
challenged yep
and so that was my mother one well your
parents born here or did they excuse me
were your parents born here yes the u.s.
yeah yeah before that like who my
great-grandfather came over from from
Austria on one side of the family
and the other side was was was from the
Ukraine understood in 1880's understood
so you know I moved to the suburbs geez
things changed quickly everybody was
like lovely yes
you know I became you know president of
the school and you know the top athlete
and and life was good life was a
astonishingly good unexpectedly good and
has more or less remain so sort of
interesting yep and and if my mother
hadn't you know sort of beaten my dad up
to move because he didn't want to move
and get us in a better school district
yeah she just did it for the school
district yeah
then that you know I wouldn't be sitting
here with you what um what drew you to
finance
well that was an accident I didn't know
anything about finance in fact I got
hired when it when I graduated from
college and I didn't even have a job
what did you think you were gonna do in
those college years after school I had
actually surprisingly no idea why were
you so focused on the enjoyment of those
four years did you have so many
interests you were crippled by that did
you have a main interest that kind of
faded towards the end of it what was the
variable there now I mean I was
interested in University in learning how
to think
excelling you know I wasn't a joiner of
organizations I mean my first English
paper I got I got a 68 on bartleby the
scrivener by Herman Melville my second
English paper I got a 66 this was a
trend even I could recognize was not so
good yep and if I continued what would
result in my not being a my
versity and so you know I fortunately
had had a teacher called me in for a
meeting and he said mr. Schwarz and he
said um we're here to talk about your
English papers I said why why would we
do that and and he said he said like I
said there's really no reason for a
meeting and he said I don't understand
why you would think that I said because
I had nothing to say and I said it
poorly yep and those papers and he said
by god you're not stupid he said you
just can't think and you can't write
yeah he said so I can't teach you both
at the same time so I'll start off
teaching you how to to write I'll give
you the answer to the essays and we'll
teach you how to write because you can't
think and write at the same time he said
then after you learned how to write I'll
teach you how to think and so I ended up
on Dean's List I went to Yale so it
wasn't like a bad school and I ended up
on Dean's List which is the top 10% of
the class by the end of the first year
so I was interested in just sort of
learning things Steve what do you think
of the current state of how we package
and process education I think I think
education is not doing a good job for
the people it's intended to help then
and you know there's probably a lot of
reasons for that you know sort of
whether it's a primary secondary or
university is different you know we have
some great universities and so that's
not a broken system in the way the
primary secondary at the level of scale
that you play in with the companies that
you get involved in at the PE level or a
hedge-fund level you know what at that
scale I'm sure you recognize the
connection point between large
organizations in the business world and
large organizations in the environment
of Education absolutely I mean they it
is stunning to me for what I do for a
living
the complete inability for the fortune
500 landscape to have adjusted to the
communications infrastructure that the
Internet at this maturity level has
created it is in your world I do not
believe the vast majority of your world
yet has recognized the stunning amount
of money that big brands waste every day
on communication and I'm talking to the
Delta of 90 you know cents on the dollar
I often say once the activist investors
actually understand
forget about printing on both sides of
the paper or travel or cutting overhead
that the sheer money that the fortune
500 landscape wastes every day on
marketing it's gonna get really
interesting it's been the inability of
Madison Avenue
you know Wall Street and the corporate
landscape to adjust to the sheer speed
of consumer behavior there's a complete
comp to the same thing on education we
continue to teach kids to memorize stuff
when the information is literally on
their phone yeah well as to the
corporate world you know you usually
have a generational issue where the
people are in charge you know aren't the
people who've learned the the
breakthrough technologies then it what
happened that's grow over the last 12
hours or Steve the compensation that
that leadership has doesn't the
infrastructure of short-term numbers and
you know being able to cash out within
two or three years after you're out of
the position even though you've only
been there for two to three years
doesn't necessarily put CEOs in today's
landscape in a position to actually care
about the health of a business a decade
from today well that one oh if I join
please because because the person you
see in that position has come up through
a variety of other positions and people
who spend their life doing something
aren't necessarily all short-term
oriented so so so they want their
organization just like you want your
you know podcast to be a winner well
let's play that a little bit differently
it's very different to be an executive
who spent 13 years within the McDonald's
ink to then become the CMO but then
transfer and go work at 3G on Burger
King is quite different than me being in
perpetuity with my personal brand well
I'm in perpetuity with my personal brand
at Blackstone sure we're not talking
about you you know I understand talking
about executives that run our companies
who transact on stock price who also can
spend 15 20 years to get to that point
when they're really making economics by
the way you'll appreciate this I don't
blame that that's human behavior I don't
think it's a negative but but but I
think it's it's it's a really
interesting dynamic that that's a
separate subject and then introduction
of an effectiveness of technology you
know for large scale organizations yeah
it is interrupted by no no problem
you'll appreciate this though I think
this is a fascinating dynamic yes but
it's also the reason that some not all
this is always a sum game right right
struggle with the taking than one step
backwards to make the capital
investments to have the patients around
consumer behavior in lieu of milking out
the infrastructure costs that they've
invested in within a half decade period
I think it's to the extent that that's
true I don't think it's an economic
decision I think it's a lack of
familiarity you know if people
understood how profoundly you know they
make it they could you know penetrate a
market or be effective they would do it
Steve right because because the other
problem is yeah if you're not doing it
and somebody else is you're gonna be
severely damaged so those there is some
rough frontier justice hi dear it's a
game of like where's the balance in the
subconscious let alone the conscious of
the individual that's leading yes their
balance between legacy and currency yes
well also comfort in other words what
that's very fair because I think a
innovating entrepreneur she or he is
only comfort in chaos whereas a very
type-a operator is only comfort in a
very different dynamic yeah that
entrepreneurs don't believe they're in
chaos you may think so but they don't
the reason you know being an
entrepreneur yourself of a certain type
or myself
you only make decisions when you feel
you're right you don't make decisions
you know to take risk
this idea that entrepreneurs are risk
takers is complete BS I'm their their
risk [ __ ] for the people that watch
the show they're risk takers from the
perspective of people who are watching
them not from themselves and Gent and so
you know nobody you think it's the
reverse yes we think the person that's
going this way is actually vulnerable
right and and so you know people who are
entrepreneurs just you see the the same
facts differently or they see or they
actually obtain different facts and
those different facts show them
something that's wholly logical in my
own case I can explain everything I do
exactly why I do it
and I'm I'm also totally open to someone
proving that that's incorrect
because I don't want to be wrong but
when I see it and if other people you
know either don't sometimes you know
what's interesting they see it but they
don't want to change what they're doing
it's it's the nature of the human beings
I'm that I've found out now because I
you know I'm not 25 years old so I've
had a lot of observations of the human
condition that that even with a
wonderfully conceived new thing if you
describe it to people hardly anybody
else will follow because they're
comfortable doing whatever they're doing
it goes back to the point earlier of the
executive
these companies in a lot of ways in my
opinion I believe that the discomfort
and then look humans are a game of
vested interests in the subconscious or
conscious it just is it's an animalistic
game it's it's I don't quite understand
it fully I'm grateful that exists
because it's it's it's helped my little
corner of the world in this perspective
of watching operators give me a couple
of your favorite operators in the
balance of let's call let's sum up what
we're talking about right now the black
and white versus the gray of operations
and strategy who's stood out some of the
investments you've made that you've
watched from afar that if really as
you've gotten closer and watched
you've just been fond of or thought
we're unique or interesting well that I
actually don't encounter people in that
way and and think about them okay you
know when I was younger there was a guy
operating within that now obsolete world
it was the head of GE named Jack Welsh
yes and and and he looked at everything
as if it was completely new he listened
to everyone intensely he he had this
unique ability still does he still alive
to to interrogate somebody and learn
everything they knew in the shortest
period of time I have ever seen and then
he'd take that on board and do that with
a succession of people and then come to
a conclusion that an organization was
doing something right or wrong could do
better should go in a different thing
and what he would do was was challenged
and pushed them to do that and he would
go wherever those insights were he this
this is a completely courageous
person with a giant brain endless energy
and took that company into the largest
market value because the just
extraordinary nature of a person no
client and and you know I I met him
before he had his job at the top and I
was asked by the head of his company to
teach him finance
that took like two days and a limited
number of hours and he could suck out of
my brain anything I had in there even
stuff I didn't know and off he went
and occasionally run into these
extraordinary humans a book I wrote the
book um because starting you know like
about 7 to 10 years ago people instead
of my going and selling them products
that we had I'd meet somebody at the top
in particular was an incident when I was
in the Middle East with the head of a
very large what they call sovereign
wealth fund which is savings of their
country yes and you know he was new and
you know I had you know an introduction
I was the first person he was going to
meet outside of his world before he was
appointed and you know instead of a five
minute handshake you know he wanted to
know how to run his organization better
because he wasn't experienced and so I
ended up spending two and a half hours
sort of telling him how to do stuff and
and you know so for me that it's pretty
easy yeah uh you know it's what I do so
I get it you certainly could do that and
I know that surprised everybody because
that that's not what was supposed to
happen and then as I would go around the
world which I do
[Music]
groups of people give us money all of a
sudden nobody wanted to hear about our
products and this particular guy the
first guy was very funny I tried to sell
him something in the middle of showing
him what he ought to be doing and he
said please mr. Schwartzman don't don't
waste my time he said we'll buy your
products anyhow your time is too
precious for me I want to continue to do
it so what happened is that be kicked
that became the seed of like there
there's something there yeah and what
happened is that started happening
everywhere I went and then I realized
that I was spending two and a half hours
every time I was seeing somebody and if
I wrote it down you know then I just
give him the book it save me the time so
the time Arbitron right that's what was
so so what happens now I end up being
here talking about it so that's like
another hour I basically blew it funny
question you know and I think this will
help the audience how much how much
competitive spirit do you have in you
for the book to do well oh I I am
exceptionally I kind of figured right
yes you know it's clearly not an
economic play the the spirit is back to
process or back to loving a game like
there's a big part of your juice I mean
for you to be here there's a big part of
your juices to make it successful yeah
if you just do something anything
doesn't matter what it is there are a
limited number of things you can do in
life that's right and if you're gonna do
one you better crush it yep I agree
right and that's part of what I would
say say in the book if you're gonna do
something because you have limited time
it should be great what I'm very curious
about this in in the last let's call it
let's give it a number two to three
years what what technology what app
maybe Alexa like has what modern
technology have you enjoyed using not a
personal level well you know I was a
technological the technological
illiterate and you know basically until
about four years ago I was using a flip
phone love you and you still have that
flip phone I'd love to flip it on even
you know I actually have a few of them
because they're so obsolete that we had
to buy the last batch of them were new
were you in this category of some of my
friends that I love to razz where you
were getting your emails printed out for
you or was it that extreme cuz I have a
couple of dear friends who are like a
little further along in their careers
and I was in a meeting three years ago
and in walks an admin with a stack of
papers and I could see the first top one
and I said brother there's no way you're
printing your emails and he said yeah I
said that's [ __ ] amazing well in that
category because that would excite me I
actually have somebody at our at our
management committee meetings who has
that stack so so so no I I actually I
read my email what about but what about
on flip and flip phone land only for
code yeah I didn't have it on your phone
yeah they would print those yes thank
you thank you for going there sir but
that yeah it became like sort of crazy
because as I travel around there be
people meeting me with these large
stacks of things and and so I realized
that was a loser
so that's when I converted yeah to to to
you know the iPad the iPhone and now and
now and now you know under efficient I
can't believe I was so stubborn do plate
and and so so now I you know you you
were you know sort of caught in traffic
a little bit and I was just sitting here
doing getting things done yeah and and
and now you know it is fascinating that
the people who generate statistics you
know for the US government and other
governments talk about lack of
productivity in the world as one of the
major drivers for growth anybody who is
living today who has all of these
devices you're actually working 16 18
hours a day you
always on its it's six seven days a week
and the productivity for guess what used
to be called white-collar workers but
you know you're wearing a sweatshirt top
so think not what could you know it's
that that the productivity is
astonishing this is cool Donnelly's my
friend it's the craftsman
it's amazing tools are in place right so
but some of these jokers here are
watching YouTube videos for three hours
during that time oh that's not for me
but you know it's amazing I just got a
picture as I was waiting for you yep
from from one of my partners in Tokyo
from New York in Tokyo with a group of
people you know everybody's smiling ya
know it's it's like a group thing so I
can feel exactly what they're feeling
it's context and it's instantaneous
speed and context so amazing when you
have questions you know to phone number
I think somebody will have a thrill but
what I would say what we start with the
question just in terms of competition my
teacher the book is a New York Times
best seller is a Amazon best book a year
old on one second best book of the year
2019 top 10 nonfiction at Barnes & Noble
so you're making some damage I just
wanted to complete when we're done with
us we'll look at our numbers as long as
I rub - that is the punchline on a show
sir Cameron how are you
you're on with Steve how are you I'm
okay thanks that's what they offer a
feel like you I was living right in the
outskirts right in the suburbs as well
very nice um yeah all right quick
question just a little recap I used to
ballet dancer and I came back home to
take care of my sick mother and right
now I'm in a position where I'm a
and being pressured to go back to school
to get some sort of a graduate degree my
mom came by my mother by my mother so
it's going I'm kind of in this weird
anyway so I'm in that but I'm also I
have entrepreneurial tendencies and I
I'm also represented and I'm working as
an actor as well so I'm in this dual
creative but you know what are you gonna
do with money but I have a side hustle
I'm just trying to figure out where my
next play is right now and how to really
communicate with people and my family to
let them know it's gonna be okay
Steve well your efforts take where to go
what to do
yep well that's that's a tough one
because I don't know you that well but
yeah I know but but you know change that
you can go to Steve's house tonight if
you want and I'm sure we thrilled to
have dinner might be able to do that but
probably not probably not but but I'm a
general term when you hear something
like that Steve and obviously well you
know you get your own question like what
what's your what are some of the
thematics well see if you had a reg a
few years if you you know sounds like
you you love the creative world and and
yeah and the performing arts of one type
or another you know so so was actually
funny I was sitting next to a lady
yesterday who's in her mid-70s who was
dancing for the Royal Ballet when she
was young apropos ballet and you
probably would do well to stick with
with that love because people tend to do
well with things they love oh well but
you don't have necessarily have to do it
just as a creative performer you can
take that and and look at ways where you
can use
your entrepreneurial instincts to take
some aspect of the performing arts and
try and commercialize those so the right
way you can you can basically satisfy
two of your needs going to graduate
school depends what kind of graduate
school typically getting more education
is a winner in the game of life
unless you're disguising because you
don't want to do well that's a separate
thing that's a separate thing but but
you know you know there's there's
something you can come up with but you
ought to keep it not as a completely
discontinuities event where you you know
all of a sudden you're you know
marketing marshmallows or something I
mean doesn't sound like a fib may not be
Kim I think your bigger issue at hand is
if you have a sick mother and she's
emotionally or theoretically or
ideologically interested in you going to
more school that's an awfully difficult
position to put a human being into
however under every circumstance even
this ridiculously difficult one I am an
absolute buyer of living your life to
make yourself happy first and then the
people around you will have the correct
collateral effects of you finding your
own happiness either when you find your
own happiness and success they've said
they've cheered all along or much more
importantly to me and the hidden game of
this that I continue to see among
society I do not want people to have
resentment towards their loved ones in a
decade or two because they followed
their path versus their own whether you
win or lose by going your route in the
end your relationship with that loved
one whether they're still here or not is
always far greater because you must
avoid that resentment at all costs when
you lay your stance proper point that
people tend to excel in the things they
love in the two things that matter the
most financial viability for sure
Commerce commercial yes I'm a fan I'm a
capitalist number two
Venus in this juxtaposition between the
balance of happiness and finances I'm
always going with tie goes to the rather
to finance
excuse me happiness I want people to
understand that this is actually without
knowing you very clear to me however
you've got to live with the consequences
of it not me but I couldn't implore you
more to execute against your own
happiness and and and hopefully you can
keep that conviction even when the crowd
and the sidelines continue to cheer and
or boo
right thank you Gary and and one thing
you know you've been such an inspiration
I've actually started a recording for a
podcast meet with people in the industry
and kind of taking your blueprint and
you know my side hustle is creative I do
tie-dye for friends and family and
anybody else who wants many and so I
love that you know say I'm sorry to cut
you off it is interrupted by Gary now
you know I know it's the key here is I
wanted to say something what I'm proud
of you for is I live in a world and we
now live in a world with keyboard
warriors and technology communication
infrastructures where people just talk
people have always taught that I can
visually see it we are a people love to
talk and not back up that talk with
action I'm proud of you for doing action
the podcast at I doubt continue to
actually move and make and create and do
that is always a variable that are
unlocks serendipity and opportunity yeah
thank you both thank you let's get
another call Steve what have we not
touched on it we're gonna do another
call do a couple of more minutes I know
you're in a busy schedule anything we
didn't touch on or things you know
obviously one thing I love about this
show is you know I've come to realize
I'm actually getting tested to see if
I'm Dyslexic
I cannot consume information I've come
to realize in written form and so I
don't tend to read a lot of books but
I'm quite audio and I'm definitely
visual and and I know Jack quite well
and we're very friendly and we have a
lot of similarities of like extracting
information out of context especially in
person forget it off the charts but what
I've loved about my audience is like
for me I don't care how one learns or
consumes they need to be self-aware and
how they do that and so this is an
audience that reads quite a bit of book
so I think we will convert some books
out of this but is there anything
anything that one needs to know about it
or anything we haven't touched on Tony
Tony Tony how are you it's Gary
Vaynerchuk you're on with Steve
Schwarzman hey Gary how are you are you
doing Steve I'm hanging in there thank
you thank you for taking my call so I
did I just have a question I'm in I've
been a real estate broker for fifteen
years now and I always had a passion for
real estate development and we just kind
of fell into it by by God by serendipity
we ended up assembling a huge
development in their shell half a
million square feet and we got a
financial partner to partner with us and
we're going to these uncharted
territories we met with them related to
big real estate funds and we're going to
these uncharted territories how do you
kind of keep that confidence and and
grit with in these new territories that
we've never explored like I'm taking
classes at NYU for development I'm doing
reading everything I can but how do you
keep that confidence and that game face
when dealing with these big guys yeah
it's it's um when you when you're doing
something that's new if you're not
confident you know that's an inhibition
to going there so so the way you get
competent confident is learning things
and there's nothing like having somebody
around who actually knows what they're
doing yeah and and so what what you
should do if you haven't already is is
whether it's hire one or two people who
really know and have been in that
environment have seen whatever you're
doing most things aren't new they're
just new to you yeah and and that's
normal and to add on the even if they're
new the nuances and the pattern
recognitions can be deployed from the
past yes every theory I have on this
mark
waste is because everybody wasted money
on radio when television became the
platform the same thing that's happening
now it's complete pattern recognition
continue Steve yeah so so you know you
you should maybe bring on what one or
two people in either a permanent or
part-time capacity yeah yep and and of
course freelance like you know there's a
lot of economic trades that can be done
you can back-end them you know on your
there's something you know depending on
the seniority and things that nature
there's a lot of yeah there's a lot more
ways to do it than people realize but
but but everything I do I I do it from a
position of real comfort not not of not
not of being worried and and the reason
is I've learned something that gets me
to that point and and yeah and and you
know to really push the button and go
forward you have to have that sense you
know Tony it's funny listening to Steve
I'm I'm kind of equate inform II I'm so
narrow I so stay in my lane like it's
really funny like I never feel like I'm
risking either
I really don't I'm so in my lane and I'm
aware when I'm out of my lane and if I
can you know the times I've risked
there's such small risks that I can I
owe it anytime I risk go anywhere out of
my lane I'm basically betting something
I can take to zero right yeah yeah yeah
because you might think you guys that
you might go to zero
Oh often you do right but I like I'm
paying for the context in the learning
yes and if I win then it's a double
Mazel but that's fine I've actually
invested for the context extract right
yeah
Tony I think if we brought on another
partner who who had some experience but
then when we're in these conversations
I'm like you're something new look it up
right away
Tony on that front honestly this is a
human game if you went to the tippy-top
of related who's my partner Steve Ross
like yeah if you just make fun of the
Dolphins you're already 3/4 of the way
there but Tony I'm really not
going on us there you know I think I
think people get intimidated way too
much this just a human game here's my
punchline 97% of donors say no anyway
yeah you know and if you stay in your
lane listen my career has been built on
the fact of the smartest people I've
come across have reacted in very
polarizing responses one way or the
other that oh my god I found this new on
sharded guy he's brilliant or I just
this guy's crazy he's completely wrong
and then by being right historically the
half that I lost up front
I've won double with yeah
so this is just about execution brother
whether they believe it people are so
insecure about other people's judgments
I prefer this is why I love the Jets so
much Steve I prefer when people think
I'm wrong or underestimate me too
actually when they think that I'm right
yeah because older brother ultimately
doesn't care if Steve and I think you're
smart or dumb or silly or unbelievable
the net result is going to be the judge
in a jury not somebody who's achieved
something in the past
yes thanks because you're so right
because we did something that nobody
else was doing we went into Westchester
to do development I left the city and
doing brokerage I said the city's kind
of maxed out at its point right now
there's so much competition I see a
shift of all the Millennials when
they're having kids they're gonna want
to go to the suburbs but still have
access to the city so we went a half
hour outside on the train line I walk
from the train into her shell yeah where
it was uncharted nothing was happening
and we assembled this huge project and
now all these big developers are coming
four years later and it's just a huge
boom and I grow that vision early on and
we were like a blue ocean strategy back
then but now it's now all the Sharks are
coming so it's amazing you guys right
you got a Tony we wish you a lot of
success good luck brother
okay Steve let's wrap up here well I
think one of the things I was trying to
to teach people is is to do things they
like because that's what you're good at
you know sort of be prepared you know
have foundational skills yes that gets
you from yes
to be and and and be very careful or
what about you what you choose to do
where you choose to deploy yourself yes
as a human resource and wait for
something that's really terrific to come
but do you sit on patience think about
it a lot you don't it's in your lexicon
it's not as a person yes I you know I'm
interpersonally impatient because I'm I
always want to get to the next thing
that's why when you have a show based on
interrupting people I said you know I do
that all the time it's what I do you
know what I've had enough
you know I yeah I've learned what you're
trying to bring value to them as well
right it's not a negative it's a
positive but but but in your own life
that that you should wait until you see
something that's got enormous potential
enormous running and and you know
because because you only can do one
thing at once with excellence yes and if
you deploy yourself on a little thing
you may be excellent but you sort of get
no place that's right about it and then
something much much more interesting
comes by and you believe it's more
interesting but you can't get out of
what you're doing because you've already
commit and a lot of people of success
don't recognize that jumping off of
something that is successful ready for
this other opportunity is the right move
but they're incapable the step backwards
for too far
yes but you always have to be measuring
always the feel whenever we go into
something I always say how wonderful can
this be how big can this be yes are all
the resources there are money the eyes
do what are they made mistakes what's
the what's the package so for me the
mistakes early in my career were I the
first three companies I invested in
after building a wine business for my
family were Facebook Twitter and Tumblr
and well pre IPO so I'm like oh I'm a
genius right like but then what I
realized was oh in the early days I was
bad
mark and David and Jack and EV as much
as the idea when they hit like I've
started realizing that I was
unbelievably consumer-centric
and I could see things that would win
one of my biggest losses an app called
yo bongo ended up being tinder three
years later I was right about the thesis
I was wrong about the executive and I
needed I needed to learn that you know
cuz I would always put myself in the
jockey position I would know how to
operate it so I needed to learn that
that's where I like made a lot of
mistakes the concept was right the
operator was wrong especially at that
early of a stage when you go later it's
a little bit easier did you have a
common mistake early in your career
there's always a learning curve yes when
you're younger when you're in your 20s
you're you're at a lot of risk yes
because you don't know enough yet not
that you're just as smart as you ever
will be I agree but you you don't have
the context agreed to make those do you
I apologize do you then believe what
that that's a very good decade to
actually be in very high-risk
high-reward happiness genre to taste a
lot of things because that's a very
opportune time in theory about
accountabilities and relationships and
many other variables you think that kids
at 22 to 30 are being too conservative
over the last several decades because
they're supposed to now be in the real
world versus actually taking advantage
of that decade with the overlay of
gathering context I think I think it's a
it's a high-risk strategy to take the
approach that you're talking about
because if you just stumble from mistake
from mistake and and and you're not
particularly gifted like yourself
well you can't self correct that that
you end up with no fundamental skills of
any type and then you're like a lost
soul understand in your 30 so so so I
think but you would agree me me that
many struggle with the relationship with
time that being in your 30s is still
uncomfortably young yes but but I was
never smarter than what I was 32 that's
your man that you're is that the number
yeah that's when you think you're the
smartest person in the world about to
you know when you're 32 because [ __ ] it
44 I think I am now
now the fact is you're not but but
you've accumulated knowledge and enough
delusion and you have such enormous
crushing energy yes the rock how old are
you that understood keep going Steve
sorry right so so so so that that's
that's in effect when you may be
extremely potent but you also may be
extremely dangerous
alive let me let me wrap up here because
they see the team's looking at me and
I'm sure you have to go and I appreciate
your extra time a couple random
questions are you on tick-tock
no but I know the guy who runs tick-tock
all the sense of the world as close as I
got have you gotten any have you gotten
any context about it do you know what's
going on and attend to 18 year old demo
on that platform no I just know they're
limited time period you know shots yeah
and you know the things growing like
crazy
globally yeah and you know that's all I
know about understood what's your
favorite emoji my favorite emojis are
heart that's a very good answer
parting shot any any last thought as we
get out of here no you know in terms of
a parting shot a lot life can be really
fantastic you know but you have to have
the ability to always be focused on
something you can achieve that's in your
comfort zone so are we talking some
bitterness right now that pushes you so
so it's a life of lifetime learning how
much do you think humility is a key
ingredient to this level of success I
think humility comes with the the the
volume of things that you do because no
matter how good you are as you ramp up
the volume you'll make mistakes and and
so you know all of us who have external
success have had
failures misjudgments and you shake your
head and say what a dummy yeah my yeah
and it's the dummy things it's the fun
stuff where you learn me and learning
how to beat yourself up in those moments
well you you actually can't beat
yourself up because they're so terrible
that that you have to rescue yourself
from that stuff and and that's that's
where you learn and and driving to make
things better make yourself better do
things almost you know like the like the
ballet dancer what is what is a perfect
pot to do look like and imagining what
those things can be and then going and
creating them great is is what's lots of
fun in life the intonation by Steve's
book because I want him and his crew to
know that a lot of sales came from this
show because I want the leverage of
legacy and I really really really
appreciate your time Steven continue to
health and success thank you thank you
great thank you good bye everyone
you